so we got this new uh Republican speaker
of the house and the good news is he
says there's insufficient evidence to
impeach Joe Biden and he gave a great
speech where he said look impeachment
requires these things and though we have
evidence of these things we don't have
EV evidence of those things so we're not
going to be able to impeach him and I'm
seeing a lot of people are kind of angry
about it but I you know I I got to be
honest uh I'm actually happy about it I
am now a I'm I'm Pro Biden uh ladies and
gentlemen I want Joe Biden to be the
Democratic nominee I am happy that the
Republicans have have uh
saw have have seen it clearly and
understand now that Joe is a great guy
and should stay president and he should
be the Democrat nominee in 2024 I
strongly hope that is the case why
because Trump is leading in five of six
swing States and Democrats actually want
Joe Biden out